and we are here
we are here it is um friday december 1
8 in the year 20
20.
and you know it's wild some people
thought we'd never make it to 2020 some
people
they call naysayers and that's a
naysayer
and you say it and they say nay
and that's a nice hair bruh but here we
are
you know when we are just rambling
through time
it's kind of interesting even if i just
sit down and do nothing i'm still
traveling at the speed
of time
it's really interesting when you think
about you could lay in a bed you could
be in a damn
coma bruh you could be in a food coma
and a real coma you could have been in a
car accident after thanksgiving and so
you double comb it
lay in there i mean just still as a damn
frozen orphan
and uh and you're still
traveling through time
you still clocking miles you know i
think it was maybe episode
60 or something they had tiny sand who
came through with a very with just um
[Music]
just that ear tickler that seasonal ear
tickler
from the great tiny sand who let's hear
it a little bit right now
remember that remember tiny come on
let's jingle bells
[Music]
there he is buddy
who could forget that man who could
forget that man and that was almost that
was probably
you know 140 episodes like 240 episodes
ago or something
jesus what have we been talking about in
here
i mean what have we been talking about
um i'm grateful to still be here with
you i'm stay i'm grateful
and i hope that you are uh i hope you're
leaning into the holidays you know i
didn't realize it was the holidays
suddenly
and then bam bro you know
like a brother with a freaking uh you
know like a brother with a ski mask this
[ __ ] just rolls up on you
you know bam the holidays is right there
and um and suddenly here we are and it
is that time of year man
it is that time of year when you get to
feel it a little bit
and especially in such a wild year let
me play a couple of sounds that remind
me of christmas
[Music]
that's the sound of like maybe somebody
you know somebody's just like on a
second date and they decide that they
actually like
each other or something and they just
kind of like
you know start to they're having whipped
cream or something they put on each
other's face or something
you know and then she kind of smirks and
he kind of like maybe he hides behind a
tree or something
and then she uh you know um
spills her eggnog in the park and he's
like oh i didn't do it you know
[Music]
so that's a little bit of christmas
right there euphoria right there that's
called a
christmas dance by arthur benson
and let's see if we get another sound
right here
oh damn this one you high as hell bro
this one you high as hell bro that's
when you believe in um
that's when you believe you drive a
reindeer that's when you believe that
um dude the other night so i went to
this deal over here
oh a couple things happened to me so one
people's getting soft man people
is getting soft dude they not fully
baking people anymore
some people they seem like like i was
when i was born i was baked at probably
about 450 degrees
for nine months you know i'm saying
that's how to
that that's how i rolled out of mama
but you got mfr's out here some soft
batch
cotton boys out here just
dude here's what happened so i went to
this town called
bowling green kentucky
and it is the home of a fruit of the
loom drawers
uh so if you ever been wearing in fruit
of the looms baby you know if you ever
got your fruit all loomed up
then you know them them [ __ ] came
straight out of kentucky
that's basically kentucky that's holding
you nuts bruh
kentucky just holding your ivories bruh
gotcha
um you know it is just supporting your
low batch daddy but um
what i'm telling you is this so i went
there
to look at some different vehicles i've
been vehicle shopping
so i decided to get me a hotel stay over
there for the for the evening
dude the guy behind i go knock on the
door of the hotel
and i understand it's core of at times
brother disease is out
so first the guy comes to the window of
the hotel the door glass door
and looks at me like i'm covered like oh
who's here is covet here like [ __ ] i'm
not covet
you know what i'm saying i'm regular
baby
so anyway the guy it was just so
ridiculous
like looking at me like he was going to
be able to judge if i had the disease
through the glass
so anyway he left me inside and um
i was like say hey man do you guys have
a room here like yeah we got a room uh
let me go see if it's clean or not i was
like all right you know when he goes
upstairs
literally he's upstairs for probably
about 15 minutes obviously he should
have cleaned it earlier
that's in his job description
and he didn't and how do i know that
because i've been
a lazy [ __ ] like this dude
that's why that's why i know cause i've
been that dude
i've been the dude that shows up to work
and doesn't work
and i look i did i was really good at
that
so anyway man finally he comes down
and uh at this point i'm thinking i
might as well just i might just want to
drive back
um you know it's only like an hour and a
half to where i'm going to
back home to my place here so anyway so
whatever he's looking on the computer
and stuff and
and at a certain point i'm kind of get
i'm getting antsy you know it's been a
while and it's getting late i want to go
get something to eat and i know
restaurants are kind of closing a lot of
things closing out like eight o'clock
nine o'clock
so i'm giving him a little bit of
pressure you know like um
you know can you can you run my card or
you know
is there anything i can do to help
saying stuff like that like a passive
aggressive
that's what they call it um
when you pretend like you are um a teddy
bear but you really a bad [ __ ] kind of
you know um
so anyway he sorry finally he goes look
i'm sorry sir
okay but i just need you to relax a
little bit i used to be in a wheelchair
like what bro
you used to be in a wheelchair you used
to be
that's what we're doing now
people are just saying you know look hey
man
look i i used to weigh 11 pounds
nine ounces when i was born okay huh
calm down cut me some slack here
that guy said i used to be in a
wheelchair when [ __ ] you broke your leg
once
you know you did some [ __ ] dirty
karate somewhere bruh
i just don't know it just man
don't make me hit you with that rat
jitsu bruh
tighten this white dude up
sorry man i'm sorry getting out of line
but it just man i don't know man that
[ __ ]
i i i it just like hey
hey buddy look i had acne when i was 14.
if you could give me a little bit of
room here
okay hey hey guy
you know i vomited uh in the middle of
the school play
when i was nine okay if you could just
step back and show some respect
it's just like what are we doing man
hey man i used to be in a wheelchair
well [ __ ] then get in a wheelchair now
if you in it
you know i'm sorry man that [ __ ] just
got me heated up
like somebody just threw some damn warm
briquettes in my ass bro
you know that's where i'm at with this
[ __ ] just
hey hey man look you know i uh
i was a i was i used to be four years
old okay i was only three and a half
feet tall at one time
if you could give me a little bit of
room here
it's just like now we're like using
whatever our weakest moment was as our
front
and i don't mind us sharing our weakest
moment man i think there's a level
of connection there there's an
opportunity you know
you know it's like we're trading
vulnerability you know
you know uh we're trading um
baseball cards there you know i'll give
you
you know i feel uncomfortable outfielder
and you give me a um look man sometimes
i'm insecure
shortstop and you know we we recognize
each other from those spaces
but i don't know if saying like look man
you know
somebody burned my hair off once okay
could you give me a little bit of give
me some give me a moment
should just lit me up a little bit
anyway that's where i'm at man but
anyway
what i meant to say is
we're alive for another week and this is
the surprise that god gave
us man this is it
whatever it is the good the bad the
nasty
whatever this is the this is it this is
this is the hey guess what's in my hand
and they show you this is what's behind
door number one through a jillion this
is it baby this is life
and you know what i think we're do i
think we're doing okay with it
thank you for being here
[Music]
come on baby
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be
so far from my home
come on
[Music]
i can feel it in my bones
but it's gonna take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake
and let myself
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
and there you go awkward fade out begins
upstairs um excuse me
look i used to be in a wheelchair and he
didn't even say when he was
at least tell me when when you were six
or last week
oh it's like some people was baked at
you know for 10 minutes at 100 degrees
bro
and they got all these ingredients but
they ain't got no they nothing's
holding them together you know and they
got these soft batch out there bruh
these soft batches and that ain't us
baby
now i'm okay if we a little bit of a
toll house marshal
i'm okay if we have that element of toll
house more solidity in us
where we a little soft but we gripping
on the edges baby gang [ __ ]
um yeah so that was wild dude i and then
oh
also i went looked at a cave look bro i
win
i gotta tell you this man oh santa's
gonna be here at the end of the episode
we got damn santa and we got a beautiful
santa man it's a
this this man has been a liaison
uh to the north pole and of
you know just the vibe of giving
and we got a natural beard santa not one
of these fake ass
you know clip-on [ __ ] we got a real
real real man right here
we got freaking chris krangle bruh
pg baby ptl baby you know what it is
praise god praise the lord
um oh so i went to this cave right
so there's this thing if you go to
kentucky
and there is a cave there because i've
been trying to be more
outgoing when i don't want to do
something i go do it
um the other day i didn't want to go to
jiu jitsu
went over to nashville mma
left out of there feeling like a champ
you know some
this lady put me in a sugar lock once
you know and i can't i still can't feel
two of my toes and i can't wink out of
one of my eyes but
god's plan bro um
what else am i talking about here uh
what are we saying
man my mind gets all readily um
oh i went in a cave they got caves over
there
and a cave is just basically like a um
it's kind of like a mountain but like i
made out of air
and so i went over when i was trying to
just uh do some touristing
in this area so i go hit this cave i'm
caving
and um well first of all at one point
they take you it's a boat you go
under this part of the ground
or or whatever it is earth rock and they
they you basically have to duck down
inside of the boat so you go first you
walk into the cave then you get in this
boat then you go down this little river
and
they uh you get down you have to go
under the rock
and you literally have to lay in the
boat like if you put your head up at all
you
will die like there is a like
it's like 40 yards just straight right
like you can't even
i can't even believe they'll let us do
it as just a customer
you know because once i'm a customer bro
i kind of
you know i once i'm a customer dog
once i give you five or six dollars or
twelve dollars for an experience
i put my life in your hands
i kind of check out i just assume look i
gave them nine dollars bruh
i'm gonna be safe whatever i'm doing you
know and it's a pretty sad
it's a pretty unfortunate and not very
you know it's kind of the opposite i
feel like of being like a navy seal or a
marine
it's like being like a um like a navy
skunk or something you know just
it's like i'm not really looking out for
myself anymore you know
it's like oh look i trust you look i
gave you seven dollars here
you know you taking me into the bat
caves i'm a
trust you're gonna take care of me so
i'm like on my phone and [ __ ] i'm not
even painting and
literally almost died like so the boat
goes under the rock
we go through the cave it's nice it's
fun it's you know it's it's
it's you're kind of pretending that it's
more fun than it is
the guy's like hey here's a hole right
here that uh
you know this hole's from 1904 you're
like holy [ __ ]
my grandfather could have seen this hole
you know just things like that you
and you you know i find myself asking
questions like
oh really that's not a question but you
know what i'm saying like
like saying things that i don't even
really want to say you know like oh wow
huh never would have thought of that
but anyway just [ __ ] like that you know
i'm upstairs
but this this episode's really gone off
the rails man
um anyway bruh what i'm telling you is
oh at the end of the thing here's what
happened
at the end of the thing the guy says
and i want to thank you guys for coming
today and i want to also let you know
that um
only like 30 years ago this entire cave
was filled
with trash right he this whole tour he'd
been telling us
how beautiful the cave was and the
temperature and
how there's only one fish that comes
this little fish named anna
or something lil anna show up and she's
the only one that come in the cave and
they you know where's hannah tonight
he's like shining a flashlight in the
water and all of this
cutesy stuff you know and i'm just in
the back like you know oh really
you know just you know i'm being i'm
being a customer
i'm being a customer that's what you do
i give you seven dollars you walk me
through the thing i
say no way and we and we
and you know and i don't die and you get
me back to where we started
and we go our separate ways
maybe i buy a gift at the gift store
usually i do
oh yeah at the very end he's like and
also i just want to thank everybody for
buying a ticket today
you know the caves used to be only 20
years ago these caves were filled
entirely to the top
with and then he started just rattling
off
just complete [ __ ] just like washers
and dryers petroleum
uh trash he's like people came from all
around to throw their trash in these
caves
he's like they even found half of a
mobile home in here
now where was the other half i don't
know
but uh and i'm like oh really
anyway bro it was just crazy that
basically what i toured was like a
hollowed out
landfill like basically somebody tricked
me
into touring out a hollowed-out landfill
in kentucky for about 13
so anybody out there that says you can't
start a small business
man get you a shovel
and get you some [ __ ] and get you a
square reader for your phone
and i bet you're gonna be good man
um merry christmas to you merry
christmas to you i want to let you know
that
we are celebrating this is not an ad i
mean it is but it's not but it's like
on january 15th 8 p.m
i'm gonna try and do some different
sketches and unique stuff
we're doing a live show
myself and this woman named
chelsea lynn and she was on the podcast
and she um
plays trailer trash tammy
and i'm excited about it you know it's
going to be
live so you buy a ticket the tickets are
10 that's a reasonable ticket
i thought about a ticket i said what's a
ticket that's reasonable i said well
look
you spin that he'll do a raffle
you know i remember when i was young um
my grandfather won a damn wheelbarrow
and he was fired up man he pushed me
around in that [ __ ] and
and then he got to drinking really and i
never really saw him again after that
but uh but before that man uh but i'm
just saying look ten dollars is a decent
amount
but it's not a crazy amount and you can
be able to sit on your couch and watch a
live show we're putting on a show this
is gonna be
uh theo and tammy's belated christmas
talent
extravaganza i'm producing this thing
it's going to be lights out i hope so on
hopefully the actual lights don't go out
because the one thing we need to pull it
off is electricity so you can buy a
ticket now in advance
and just remember to tune in uh
that friday evening there's nothing
going on that evening i checked
there's no big football dustin poirier
and conor mcgregor is going to fight the
week
uh later uh so you're good
you can tune it's gonna be fun we got
some dope sketches uh we have live
talent show
um we're gonna be hosting the whole
evening uh we got some live musical
performers um
it should be similar to that show hee
haw there's an old show on youtube if
you get to check it out
h-e-e-h-a-w
um and you know what i'm looking forward
to it man
i really wanted to make it a special
night
so i hope that you will be there uh with
me and support
um there'll be a live chat where people
can chat during it if they want to
uh and you'll also be able to watch it
for like um i think a few days
afterwards online
so um
i want to let you know right now that
2020 was rocky
it was rocky like you nuts daddy
but it's new year new balls with our
sponsor manscaped
by now those i mean manscaped is the
only i feel like it's the only
people in the below the belt grooming
game
if you let yourself go in 2020 you grew
a hair you grew a um
some people grew a little you know
little just a rapunzel off they nuts
some people just grew that [ __ ]
you know somebody some people drew just
just
that little badger tuft off the back of
the ass but
off the top of that lookout off the top
of that brown lookout you got that
little badger tuft
but now you can change that all up
manscaped is here for you to reboot and
stay clean and shaved in 20 21.
i've had a ton of body hair man i
remember
and i've shared this before the first
time i shaved my body hair and i mailed
it to my mother
in a bag because she was you know it's
hair it's back hair back hair back hair
and this backyard i've had since i was a
child you know
oh excuse me man you know i used to be a
i used to be uh five years old so
if you could relax a little
um anyway the third generation tremor
with skin safe technology the skin safe
trimmer will reduce
nicks to your body and your ball bag if
you have any
20 20 was awful so make sure your boys
are refreshed and ready to go for 2021
manscaped even threw in their shed
travel bag keep all your goodies stored
comfortably
a guy with hairy balls is like the year
2020. don't be that guy
get 20 off in free shipping at
manscape.com
t-h-e-o get 20 off and free
shipping at manscape.com
theo that's 20 off free shipping at
manscape.com
happy new year to you and your balls do
you have a hard time taking pills
i do you know i remember somebody gave
me a pill once
and uh and honestly it was my friend
billy conforto r.i.p
and he's probably was one of the
i bet he's one of the 60 or 70 greatest
uh
homosexual prize fighters that never
fought for money honestly
and i miss him every day man and we
actually we gotta
you know we we need to we're gonna build
a bench over there in his honor
near where he lived over there in
laplace louisiana
but um he gave me a pill one time and i
drove off the road
not long after he gave it to me and
honestly i thought the dude might have
tried to give me a bj while i was passed
out but i don't think he did
you know and and praise god bro but um
but anyway uh and that's why i don't
take pills man and i never have really
uh
but um what i'm saying is if you have a
hard time taking pills
you're not alone get the only sildenafil
and
tala lawful chewables by visiting
bluechew.com
if you like sex you'll love bluechew.com
they offer men a performance enhancement
for the bedroom at bluechew.com you can
get the first chewables with active
ingredients
uh sildenaful and tadalafol
the chewables from blue chew can be
taken on a full or empty stomach and
that's nice
you could have a damn half a pie to a
pot of uh rice-a-roni
and still do you a little dick upper
the online physician consult is free so
it's cheaper than those other two
pills it only takes a few minutes to
connect with the bluetooth affiliated
physician
the chewables from bluetooth.com are
made in the usa you ain't getting them
foreign uh
hitters and trust me i've gotten them
foreign tongue [ __ ] hitters baby and
then [ __ ] will
make your legs sweat but keep your penis
uh you know real soft cotton soft
they call that cotton dick anyway here's
a great deal for you guys visit
bluechew.com and get your first order
free
when you use promo code t-h-e-o just pay
five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w-dot-com
promo code theo
that's all i really know at the moment
let me thank um we had a lot of great
calls that came in we got santa's coming
santa santa's coming
dude i remember growing up in louisiana
they had a they did an event
every year and an event is like
something where you don't
you know it's like regular time but it's
more special than that
and um they used somebody would fly
in a plane through the air around town
and they would play christmas music out
the plane
this was a small plane a crop duster
so they'd put on these jovial tunes and
they would hit the air
and so moms they would bring us outside
on the porch about maybe 6
40. and say do you hear it do you hear
it
and they would just be like dashing
through this you know it would be this
something you hear and it would just be
it would blow your mind
and it lifted you up with that christmas
spirit
and i thought that that was so special
that a town did that that they invested
in that sort of thing
and i think that that's important that
kind of stuff
because that you know who knows if that
moment right there might have
you know kept the magic alive in me
and made me believe in things because
you know
santa is something you believe in but
it's something that's just your it's
just your first kind of
it's kind of like your first romance in
a weird way
you know you're hopeful and you're
excited and there's
possibility and there's a date there's
december 25th
and it's just
you know it has all the elements of
romance but no sex
nobody getting sex
and there's something that you know
there's something special about that
because i think if you can make that
time romantic enough to a child
in an and you know or you know you know
romance but non-sexual
you know if you can make it entertaining
enough to a child in that way then it
can um
they'll carry that same ambiance
and the same belief of possibility into
the world
in other aspects man um
i want to thank you guys for supporting
the podcast i want to thank you guys for
being a part of my life this year
and i know i say that a lot but i think
sometimes it's just hard for me to get
across um
you know i haven't been feeling good
this year you know i have not been
feeling i say that a lot i think i might
have a pinched nerve in my neck or my
back
finally got an mri today um
but i j you know this [ __ ] sounds
freaking gay bro but it's been in pain a
lot
or not gay bro you know what i'm saying
um
painful but just kind of like
you know i sound like that dude like hey
man
i you know i used to have baby teeth if
you don't mind look if you don't mind
bro i used to be in the third grade
okay um we had some great calls that
came in
and uh i want to thank kenny again last
week from portland who
um gave away a nice gift and promoted
others
uh to do the same thing here's a call
that came in
hello theo this is bert from the dirty
south
dirty birdie
let's hear it baby um i was just calling
to let you know i just finished your
third place babies episode
and man that thing just blew my mind
with all the calls about the
donations for the ps5 and people were
just
reaching out to you man it really it
touched my heart really
and made my heart like blow up like you
know
like the grinch really like oh hell yeah
that's like god taking a big puff off
that love joint and blowing that [ __ ]
right into your [ __ ]
third lung baby that love long the heart
gang
[ __ ] homework it just it warmed my chest
it's 709 in the am
down here in austin texas
and um that's joe rogan country down
there
and that wild that's joe rogan country
down there onward
i just wanted to call to let you know
how that how that made me feel
um i guess
i kind of i guess it kind of makes me
you know it like rejuvenates my my uh
my uh my spirit like my christmas spirit
and uh i just wanted to call you and
thank you for that
and uh that's it i guess
appreciate everything you do man gang
brother
and that's not it man that's a lot you
know you saying that is a lot
and uh you know being a man that's brave
enough to make that call and just say
hey man thank you this made me feel a
certain way
you know that means a lot that's hard to
do sometimes
um
you know as men we get so we don't get
acclimated to
letting our feelings also be a badge of
courage
or a sword or a shield you know
you know i can tell you something made
me feel a certain way but also at the
same time
be powerful with it
you know when i think in the future
we're really going to learn and really
start to acclimate
to what these other powers we have are
even our in our own vulnerability
because i think there's a way to be
powerful and be vulnerable
but not be weak
um but thank you man that means a lot to
me that at 709 am man that
look it all started man that guy kenny
called him wanted to be nice
dude my friend dan laganna called in the
other day he created a show called
american
vandal on um on netflix he's
uh working on this new um
the tiger king series and he's just a
talented and just a heart just a man
that's all heart bro
he must have 40 aortas bro and he called
and i didn't even know he listened to
the podcast
and he called and he said hey man i just
want to say i listen to your episode
and if there's anything i can do to give
if there's another mom out there i can
give to let me know
and first of all it just touched me so
much that because he said hey man it
really touched me
and it just man that was you know that
was cool man first of all here's a guy
that i really admire
who's like saying man i listen to your
podcast i'm like that's so cool bro
thank you that's crazy um
and then that he care you know just that
it made him
feel um
and i and it was just night it was just
and meant
so many people called wanting to then
give and do
something in like i don't know
there was honestly just not there was no
way to facilitate it all
there was just no way to facilitate it
all in such a last minute way
um but maybe next year we'll do like a
platform or something
to see you know what's possible but
thank you to everybody that called i
mean
so many people called in offering to be
of help
pretty powerful man um
let's take another call right came in
right here
hey theo this is melissa from houston
and um
i just got through listening to um the
latest podcast
um third place babies and wow
just um man that one really hit me
uh such what a great podcast
and you have the the best fans the best
audience they're so generous
um and uh just thank you for
that episode um
and i it made me think of what i could
um
what i could give to you and
well i can't you know literally i guess
really give you anything but
um i just thought if i could give to you
for
i would give you the ability to feel
okay
and to really really feel how much
you're loved
because you are um
that's my wish for you for this
christmas holidays and it'll be in my
prayers for you
and um just thank you thank you for that
episode it really touched me
and um and that's it
well thank you uh melissa that's sweet
of you
yeah that's that you know that's very
sweet of you and i um
and just a lot of calls came in like
that of people that just felt
just felt something man just felt
something
you know so much so so so many times in
life man i just want to feel something
man
i just want to feel something and
life can get mundane it can get
monotonous it can get where we focused
on the
the excel spreadsheet instead of the xl
lens
that can happen between humans and
and from moments and uh
you know thank you yeah you know i wish
i had a bottle of okay pills
that i could take in the morning
you know i've never really felt okay man
woman sorry melissa i've never
i just
you know it's funny and uh in working
with sponsors over the years and and
working in some 12-step stuff and
a lot of times i find i would call my
sponsor and i'd say hey is everything
okay
and they're like yeah man what do you
mean
i was like it's just just tell me
everything's okay please just tell me
everything's okay
[Music]
and and they're like yeah everything's
fine man
everything is fine
and i think i just never you know i
never heard that i never heard that
growing up nobody was around i said hey
man everything's okay
everything is okay so i always was just
frenetic it was like
i was always this loose wire that had
come down in a storm and no one ever
addressed it really and it's nobody's
fault it's just
it's just you know that's how i was and
i'm not sad about it or anything i'm
just
you know being okay was never something
that
i was uh so that's sweet of you
you know and maybe that's a night that'd
be a nice new year's resolution for me
to just think about
everything's okay
and if you need to hear that
you know my friend bill morris man he's
a white guy
and uh which is easily to be expected
from the name bill morris
but he texted me um this is probably a
year ago
and it just said hey it just said
everything is okay
and i talked to him few days later i
said hey man why did you send that what
was going on
he just said hey i just i had a feeling
maybe you were
in a space where you didn't know if
everything was okay and so i just wanted
you to know it was and so i just that's
what i sent
and i was like man it's so funny because
right when i read it i was like
all right bro all right and everything
is gonna be okay
and so i'm telling you that you know if
you years been choppy or if you
you know you don't know if you're doing
okay raising your kid or if you
um
if you don't know if you're loved or if
you don't know if
man i don't know [ __ ] got me feeling
some type of way now
yeah if you don't know if everything's
gonna be okay i'm just
i'm sending you this audio text right
now and just saying hey bro
you know everything everything is going
to be okay
you're doing good
you know you're okay as you are
damn bro i'm gonna get
i'm gonna hear about this at jiu-jitsu
bro but
but uh but no for real man you you know
you're doing good if you don't know if
you're a good brother you don't know if
you're a good boyfriend you don't know
if you're a good husband
you don't know if you're a good wife you
don't know if you're a good human
you don't know if you really have any
relationship with god but you know he's
looking for you any of that
like like i'm not here to give you any
message i'm just letting you know that
you know wherever you are is you're okay
you know and that everything is going to
be fine
um and i don't even know why i'm saying
that right now i just but i feel
some type of way bro and i feel really
compelled
to say that so praise god man
but thank you melissa
yeah i i i
i think my whole life i've just had to
try to be
something because i never knew what i
was
and i you know and and and
there and and i used to feel sad about
that sometimes but now it's like look
that's
that's how you get different things
that's how you get art
that's how you get things
perspectives um
but thank you for those warm wishes
melissa that's really sweet of you
uh let's hear what else we got here um
we got a couple of other honestly some
of these are just nice messages
that came in and so i'm gonna play some
of them and then we got santa's gonna be
in here in about 10 minutes bruh
freaking santa
can you believe it
hi fear um my name is renee i'm from
brisbane australia
hello renee and thank you for calling
here from brisbane
and god i love australia man
sorry i was just imagining me just
really [ __ ] australia bro because i
just
love it onward um i was just calling to
say um
in your last episode you gave away that
ps5 and it prompted you to
give to some other single moms like the
gift card and
the xbox maybe um yeah we did we
followed up with those moms and carried
through with those things
um and i know you're not taking me to
task i just wanted listeners to know
uh and you know what i'm gonna hit up a
few more some other people some other
people did submit people i'm gonna i'm
gonna hit up a few more tomorrow and
just see what else we can do um
you know and and i wish i i wish i had
known how much outreach there was going
to be an offers for help because i would
have
planned ahead and had somebody you know
on staff to help more maybe nick can
help out and
we can get sean help out here onward i'm
sorry to interrupt you renee
and i just wanted to let you know it's
really
inspired me to put in a bit more effort
this christmas
help a few more people out like i think
we all
sometimes get stuck in our own bubble
and we just want to help ourselves
um but yeah you've
made me realize
there's more out there and it's
been great it's yeah
seeing people smile makes me smile
you know um i do know
you know i i i really can relate to that
it's so funny
uh so often like i just never
i've never been a big
you know i've always been an envious
when i'm doing uh
stand-up which seems like doesn't even
exist anymore but
i've always been envious of the crowd
i've always been envious i just want you
know i want to sit there and i want to
man they're having fun they're laughing
you know i just always i think i think
what i wanted to be the most i wanted to
be that person in the crowd
but i just have never been really good
i've just never been good at having that
much
joy
um i'm always so concerned i'm always
scared
you know my best friend uh growing up
this fellow will teague man and he's a
you know if they ever if they ever make
a space shuttle that's taking people
directly to heaven and they put two
people in and he should damn be one of
them but
um
you know he i grew up always at his
house and i got to see his mother years
later and she said you were always such
a scared
kid and i said dang man was i
um but anyway uh
going back to what you said there renee
um yeah i always i've always admired the
people in the crowd that were having a
good time i always wanted to be them
but the only way i could get to even
close was to be the person
saying stuff to get people to laugh
you know it was like the closest i could
get was man maybe if i create enough of
that i'll i'll become it
um and there's probably more in there
but look that all started with kenny
from portland
so you pinning the tail on the wrong
donkey
hey theo this is kenny calling from
portland uh
i had an idea here i have a playstation
5 that i got from my work
uh i'm not really a big gamer right
there
but i can relate to you renee when you
say you know i i'm not like you know i
feel so sad
a couple of months ago this company sent
me a sweatshirt
same company that sent me this switch or
feet it's called and they got nice
sweatshirts and
they're pricey though it's a pricey
piece man i mean it's cheaper to
probably buy a damn lamb and hang it off
your arms you know
or carry it around your damn neck or you
know get a [ __ ] thick sheep and carry
that [ __ ] on you
but um but they sent me some sweaters
and one of them i knew it wasn't my
style
and i knew i didn't want to wear it and
i thought maybe i you know you know who
would really look good in this i thought
was
there's a woman who cleans my apartment
she comes once a week
and that's okay and she's awesome she's
honestly so awesome
and i look forward to her coming she
speaks spanish i get to practice spanish
with her
and she brings her kids sometimes and
they're beautiful kids and they're funny
and
it's like this little connection i have
to like um
they're from central america it's like
this little connection i have like to my
father sometimes and
um and i knew
immediately i knew man i should just
give that to her i'm never gonna where i
should just get and i didn't
you know and that's fine it's okay i'm
not crying about this whatever but it's
like
i i just i want to get to the place in
my life where i trust
every little instinct that says give
this give this do this
to give this i want to be able to
be that
whatever that is
you know whatever that is i just that's
what i want to be
man um
but thank you man i look all of us have
been affected by kenny's generosity
and that's pretty dope insurance can be
complicated
and that's why the zebra was created
when you use the zebra.com insurance
finally feels like it's in black and
white
no more confusion just honest rates from
real companies that's right
the zebra is the nation's leading
insurance comparison site
for car and home insurance you know it's
tricky when you go to get insurance you
don't know what the hell is going on on
the site
and then bam praise god you figure it
out
and that's what the zebra does is zebra
dot com answers a few questions to
compare accurate
insurance quotes for free it's the
easiest place to do it
now you're going to go to places they're
going to try to get your information
don't give them that
go to the zebra.com it protects your
personal information
make sure there are no hidden fees or
surprises you can secure your insurance
from
the zebra.com over the phone from one of
their very licensed insurance agents
how much money can you save on a car or
home insurance car
or home visit the zebra.com
theo that's t-h-e-z-e-b
dot com slash t-h-e-o for insurance in
black and white
that's it get your insurance stay
insured you got to
i'm also gonna let you know right now
that life can be stressful
even under normal circumstances
2020 has challenged even the most
difficult
parts of our lives you need stress
relief
that goes beyond quick fixes yes you do
and that's why you need headspace
you probably tried meditation before and
it didn't work right
or maybe you felt like you were doing it
wrong that happens to me a lot
i'd be like what am i just sitting here
what if i think of something is that
okay what am i i don't know
wouldn't it be great if there were a
pocket-sized guide that helped you sleep
focus act be better
well there is and if you have 10 minutes
headspace can change
your life if people keep telling you to
try meditation and you're like when
when would i have the time well check
out headspace
you don't need to spend a ton of money
to reconnect with yourself
you know there's something beautiful
that meditation has given me at times in
my life
when i've used it it's given me a moment
between hearing something and reacting
it's given me just a moment
just a quarter inch of a moment
and that's where i can make a better
decision for a mood boosting workout
check out headspace.com just 30 days
ahead space
lower stress by 32 imagine that
and just four sessions can reduce
burnout by 14
jesus i will be on here tonight check
out the wake up
daily original content intended to
inspire
your day from the moment you wake up you
deserve to feel happier and head space
is meditation made simple go to
headspace.com
th that's headspace.com
theo for a free one-month trial with
access
to headspace's full library of
meditations for every situation
this is the best deal offered right now
go to headspace.com
theo today and i gotta say man
i have used headspace and they have a
great way of taking
you through how
to meditate it's not just like okay
now you're meditating it's okay here's
how you do it
the they're actually they're saying the
questions that arise in my head
so that i navigate it and then it's okay
and then it becomes a practice man you
talk about working on the outside
working out on the outside try working
out on the inside and that is
head space all right we got a
call what's up theo this is shane from
california
um sugar shane baby
and i know a couple shanes was gay men
that i knew
and i'll be honest with you brother and
i'm not saying anything and it doesn't
matter
doesn't matter who you love shane but a
lot of times a gay man will have the
name
shane and they call him sugar shane
onward i was just calling to uh
talk to you about something my son
wanted to talk to me about last night he
comes in from the cul-de-sac
playing with all the kids and he says
dad i need to talk to you
can you come back to my room and i said
yeah cause he's got younger brothers
and he said dad is uh santa claus real
now he's a fifth grader so
maybe he should already know maybe not i
don't remember when i found out
but he heard through the word
of the cul-de-sac that that's sackchat
they call it
gang bro santa claus wasn't real
so he told me he wanted me to be real
with him
and i was real with him and i damn is he
a little brother dog he wants you to be
real with him
praise god baby onward laid it down and
he i could see a little bit
of the little boy
kind of seep out of him a little bit
you know with that santa magic
disappearing
um damn you hit him with the damn truth
huh
it was kind of a
uh it was a real it was a real
conversation
and um anyways with christmas coming
uh i thought there might be a lot of uh
conversations like the one i had with
uh other people's kids um
anyways i hope you have a good christmas
out there in
nashville tennessee
thanks brother amen man i appreciate it
and thanks for the call and
you know uh
i remember somebody told us santa died
when i was young
and god
god it was hell man and i remember our
neighbors even at one point tried to do
a thing where they buried a fake santa
like they
did a damn fake funeral and had a little
bit of like a santa a little
you know like a fat sleeve hanging out
that [ __ ] or whatever
you know half a gift you know quarter of
a uh
you know teddy ruxman
um you know or you know one you know
they have you know some damn voltron or
something hanging out that [ __ ] and
they say santa's dead you know
or something so yeah there was a lot of
staged things going on people trying to
save money parents
you know somebody a parent would spend
all the money on dope
and then they'd do a fake fire and throw
a half a santa suit in it
see how damn santa [ __ ] you know
cooked himself off doing
you know doing dope or whatever um
but we talking about man uh
oh yeah it's hard to tell them i think
it's hard to tell because i don't have
any kids you know
i need to have a damn kid soon but what
i am telling you is this man um
that
i think a way to tell them is
say look santa's alive as long as you
want him to be alive
and the second you quit believing in him
he doesn't exist anymore
because that because then i feel like
you might be setting them up for a good
metaphor in the in their growing lives
now whatever you put your faith in
whatever you really
practice and you put your energy into
it could be meditation it could be
loving your spouse
it could be you know aiming to be a
better parent
it could be um learning art
it could be stand-up comedy it could be
anything
if you keep believing in it
then it has a life
if you keep practicing it
then it has an existence
things aren't just alive out there
we have to make them happen whether they
be dreams
whether they be visions whether they be
businesses whether they be love
whether they be
whether they be anything
you know whatever you focus on grows
baby and
and i'm not preaching at you i'm not i
mean it's some of this stuff i'm just
you know
it's the stuff we kind of always talk
about in here and i don't even know why
we do sometimes but that's okay
and and this is our world
and uh but look i i applaud you for
being there in that moment and staying
in the moment
some dads would throw a beer at the kid
you know or go piss and never come back
say i'ma tell you when i go
i'm gonna go piss i'm gonna tell you
when i get back you know
but you being honest you're being honest
dad
but yeah the second that you whatever it
is in the world if you keep the magic
alive the magic stays alive
so we can take that out into the world
man
look there's some other great calls that
came in and i want to get to some of
them um
but santa claus is coming to town
and uh you know i'm excited man
i'm excited they did that in my small
town somebody went out of their way to
do something special to make me feel as
a kid for
probably extra years that santa was
reeling who knows
would hearing that sleigh go by in this
in the sky made me
do or made me feel or made me believe
who knows
who knows the residual effect of taking
a little bit of time out
and making somebody feel good or doing
something extra
who knows baby
you better watch out you better not cry
you better watch out i'm telling you now
santa claus is coming
to town
he sees you when you're sleepy
he knows when you're out late
he knows if you've been bad or
good so you better give him a break
oh jingle bells jingle bells
jingle all the way
oh what fun it is to ride in a one-horse
open sleigh
shorty work work work
damn sorry that song just obviously took
a detour into
atlanta today's episode is brought to
you by
magic mind you know it's the alternative
it's the alternative to uh
energy uh to five hour energy
you want a flow state it's it's the flow
state you want
it's the ability to create flow state in
your life
you know take having coffee in the
morning having a a
you know a monster energies and that's
crazy pouring [ __ ] frankenstein right
now you throw you pouring dracula right
down your throat
try magic mind it's the alternative
it's the organic five-hour energy it is
you can create your own flow state help
yourself be your best self magic mind
dot co use promo code theo for 10
off all right let's get to the guest now
uh today's guest
needs no introduction um
and you know i don't even know how we
get introduced to this man in our lives
but we're so very grateful that he
exists
and he's here today with us this is the
man himself the stepson of father time
mr k kringle they call him up in the
hood baby
kris kringle santa claus
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
yeah cause i'm just like do you even get
cell service like if you're in
the sky uh i do
my sleigh and reindeer are all fully
equipped with
all the latest technology really you
guys got like the technology package oh
absolutely
we were retrofitted about uh four years
ago
wow that's wild um has there been like
um
like this year has it been a lot scarier
for kids to like request
gifts has there been like a lot less
interaction like what's it been like for
you like interacting with the kids
well for me where i'm at four days a
week
it's same business as usual however
there are some parents that
want their children to steal socially
distance so we put them on the bench
seat that i normally would sit on
and then behind it we have a little
fireplace and a christmas tree
and i hide behind the christmas tree and
then i peek out and
i do a sh or a surprise face look
type of thing i love that so that works
out fine and some of them they'll do
the first picture while they're sitting
on my lap with their mask on and then
they'll take the mask off after that
that way they want to
i guess chronologically capture the 20
20 moment you know
are some kids more special than others
santa do you think
well there are special needs children
yeah and they come and see me all the
time too
and they're the they're very around me
pardon me you mean like year-round
year-round see because i am santa
and i am naturally fat and i have white
hair and a white beard
uh children come up to me all the time
during the year well
if i'm out grocery shopping or we're out
at a restaurant or someplace like
sometimes even when i'm in the gas
station
yeah filling up the vehicles uh oh yeah
if i've been sniffing gas i'll accuse
somebody of being santa that's for sure
so i always uh have little coins or
trinkets or things of that sort i'll
spend a moment or two talking with them
and then i'll give them something
um how did the spirit of christmas kind
of start like in your heart and stuff
like that
yeah i've always loved children okay and
that's the main reason that i do this
is to uh so the children who will have
the best experience with santa's
possible each year
one of the early macy's uh
new york city santas his name was
charles w howard
and he's famous for having quoted the or
creating the quote he airs
who thinks santa enters through the
chimney
santa enters through the heart and
that's very very true
yeah i guess there's a there's an
element of just keeping that alive in
children huh keeping that
that that ability for anything to be
possible
sure everything's possible yeah yeah do
you feel like a responsibility whenever
you see the kids like um
do you feel some like uh is it hard to
gear up and just show up every day and
be
santa uh the season does get long
uh and mrs claus is always ready for it
to end cause she does a lot to help me
get ready every day oh does she really
oh yeah
she curls my hair and my beard with
little mini hot rollers ooh
damn and uh from the time i get into the
shower
till the time i walk out the front door
it's
about a two-hour process 45 minutes of
which i'm sitting there with these
curlers everywhere
and where'd you meet your mrs claus at i
met mrs claus in virginia beach
oh yes and it's been 33 years
since then we've been married and will
um
will mrs claus kind of uh does she have
like a favorite meal that she prepares
for you kind of
yes cookies all the time cookies really
so that's not just a myth right no
that's not a myth
i love every kind of cookie there is so
when a children ask me what's my
favorite cookie
i say i love all the cookies i've never
met a cookie i didn't like
now was there um was there ever a time
where there was i heard like
rumors and stuff that there was a time
where some of the reindeer wasn't
you know there was like some of them was
kind of struggling doing
you know not drugs but like just
struggling with stuff that they were
going through was there ever a time
where they were going to replace some of
the reindeer
well we're always have reindeer in
training okay
for example this year i've got two
reindeer
that are hoping to make santa's reindeer
team next year and their names are holly
and jolly
oh really oh yeah okay they're working
hard
a couple max preps out there i like that
so they're kind of on the uh junior
varsity right there on the junior
varsity that's right
and so what kind of training and stuff
do they have to do for reindeer because
i imagine like at some point part of the
element is you grant them the ability to
fly
well that's through waffle dust you
don't know what waffle dust is
well let me tell you i think it's
probably the reason i've lived as long
as i live
a lot of people think that i go to
deliver all the toys in 24 hours
they think that i go around the world
this way
east to west east to west east to west
but i don't i go
north to south north to south and every
time
i get back to the north i land at the
north pole
people don't realize it there's so many
good children
in the world now and it takes so many
toys to take care of them
i can't have a sleigh large enough to
haul all those so you got to make all
those trips so we make all those trips
there's in
in the world there's 24 time zones and
we do
one time zone every hour that's how we
can do the whole world in 24 hours
and when we land at the north pole
here's what happens
three things they always come out and
put all kinds of more toys in the slate
mrs claus meets me at the sleigh uh
and gives me some coffee or a hot
chocolate or cider or something like
that
she'll prep you up she'll kind of keep
your morale up and
this special elf that we have who
has the formula to make waffle dust she
comes out
and one of the things that she does
before we take take off again
is she hovers and she sprinkles waffle
dust all over the reindeer
oh yeah and all over the sleigh and then
right there
beside me on the sleigh is a giant bag
of waffle ducks
damn right okay because i'll tell you
what
i traveled some of the places in the
world and the
weather's just terrible i mean it's
really really bad
yeah and you don't want santa and the
sleigh sliding off these
icy roofs so what we do is we circle the
house sprinkle a little waffle dust on
it
and that way the reindeer have sure
footing whenever they land
i like that yeah it's great here's a
question that came in for you right here
santa here's a question from one of our
listeners what's up theo what's up maul
santa
just taking a dump right now oh one to
ash
mall santa sir what is the rowdiest
uh kid you ever had on what did they ask
for what did they do
and uh in general how do you deal with
the situation like that
um especially with parents there uh
what are you doing so gang gang take
dumps
jesus well the rowdy children uh
i talk with them a little bit about not
being as rough and tumble as they are
that that's just a big show that they're
trying to put on
okay and as far as the children that ask
for everything because i have some
children
they bring the whole toys r us book or
whatever whatever are they getting their
toys out of
and they're being greedy oh yeah they're
being greedy and so what i tell them i
said
now if the last little boy or girl that
had come to see me
who asked for everything if i said okay
i'll bring you everything
then you wouldn't get anything because
it'll all be gone so we all have to
share in this world
and what do kids want over the years
what have you noticed that children
really want them
is there a couple of common gifts that
really stand out
well over the breadth of time i know
each year there's kind of a novel gift
believe it or not every year i get a
bunch of requests
for pogo sticks are you serious oh yeah
i do wow and sometimes i get i don't get
so much anymore hula hoops
yeah but i get even this year i probably
had 20 or 30 children come and ask me
for
pogo sticks and is there do you go ahead
sir and of course there's a lot of
children that want the
the uh nerf guns okay and that's fine
and uh and if somebody wants a regular
gun did you help them with that or is
that you
tell them i cannot legally bring them
a real gun because they're not old
enough i see okay
i see and uh what's the oldest person
that's ever sat on your lap probably 102
years old
no way oh yeah i've had them all the way
from
three days old to 102 102 how long was
that line to see i wonder huh
well you know in the malls there's a lot
of long lines
okay so i try to move along fairly
quickly
and um what did the 102 year old want
for kristen do you remember
she just wants to be able to see 103.
so she just wants a little bit of time
she wants a little bit of time
what's some of the cuter answers that
little children have given you over the
years you think has it been
well i've had some uh
come and pull on my beard and then
realize it's real and run off
sometimes they may have a sudden
expletive or two on the way out
oh yeah yeah uh i had one little girl
who uh she was probably
maybe six years old and i asked her what
she wanted for christmas
and she said cole and i looked at her i
said you want cole
and i looked at her mother who was
standing there beside her
i said to her why do you want coal
and she says diamonds she made the
connection that if you crush cold
you'll get diamonds out of it she's that
long-term thinker and her mama
clapped her hand and said that's what
i'm talking about girl okay
so she think he'd drop her off a bag of
briquettes huh yeah
dang man some of these women starting to
think long term
you know they are that's one way to do
it um
do you remember me when i was a kid or
no oh i do you were quite a handful in
was i yeah
but you had fun you turned out pretty
good thank you i would imagine in the
north pole there can be a lot of like
things get to seclusion
and even you know in cold temperatures
people suffer from depression sometimes
in isolation
you know and eventually even sometimes
alcoholism drug use do you guys see any
of that up there we don't have any
alcoholism and drug use but what we do
is we have one of them blue light things
that's supposed to help raise your mood
all the time so we have that
oh dang bring me one of those i'll tie
it around my neck
that's what i need now do some kids some
kids freak out when they see you santa
some kids can't handle it
a lot of time you'll see uh you know
mothers will put a picture of their
child crying on santa's lap what's going
on there
what is it well some of them cry a lot
some of them will cry a little bit and
some of them will just have a
total meltdown how do you handle that
though like what do you do at that
moment
well here's what i do i if they put them
on my lap and they start to cry
i'll hold them as close as i can so they
won't hurt themselves trying to get off
and that type of thing
and then at the very end before i let
the child down
i'll also cry too
because that makes a good picture for
for the parents yeah
and then i'll put the child down and
sometimes the photographer will take a
picture of the
child leaving yeah with fear on their
face sometimes
now there's a lot there's like uh
there's over the years you see a lot of
uh santas that get
you know they show them like on bad
santa drinking alcohol and stuff like
that do you
ever have you have you ever had to use
uppers or downers or side splitters or
whatever to really
uh get through the work week no not at
all amen brother
amen and is it ever do you see it in the
industry though
no i don't i haven't seen it uh not in
the real bearded santas that i see
is there a lot of kind of not beef on
the streets but is there like a lot of
like discrepancy between fake bearded
and real bearded sanders to me there is
well there's something not real there's
just
there's a difference in the professional
now professionality of them
now there are people men who have
well there's called designer beards okay
these are made out of either real human
hair
or sometimes yak hair and once they're
put on properly you can't tell that it's
not
a real beard really okay and there's
some people that it's called designer
beards
okay now those sandals are just as
professional as
the rest of us that have real beards uh
it is the this is the sands that have
the fake bellies and the fake beards and
the fake wigs
that are uh
of poor quality that tend to be the ones
that you have problems with
yeah yeah i think people that aren't in
it for the real
that aren't in it that aren't fully in
the heart got to be in the heart if you
don't have it in the heart
the children will see right through you
wow yeah
yeah if you somebody's getting all
yacked out on that yak i think that
would be
uh that's interesting how nice is yak
here is it pretty nice
oh yeah and it's expensive too it's like
uh
uh two to four thousand dollars
for a good beard and
wig set um
dang that's very expensive that's pricey
man
i don't know where you would get a yeah
i don't even know if they still make
yaks anymore i don't know it's like oh
yeah they are
and there are people who service
the santa industry with suits
all kinds of other stuff that santa's
need as well as
beards and wigs if they need those um
where are some of the places you've been
stationed at over the years santa like i
know in since
in santa's line of work there's a lot of
places you get called on to serve
basically
it's almost like the military in a weird
way it's almost like the um
it's like the military of the heart you
know uh especially around the holiday
times
where are some places you got called on
to to survey well i've been
in orlando florida i've been in wichita
falls texas
i've been in baton rouge louisiana
i've been in novi michigan which is
north and east of detroit a little bit
i've been in modesto california wow
it's a lot actually been in nashville
yeah at cool springs galleria mall on
07.08
how was that was that fun it was a lot
of fun i bet that was a
big time too that was before too much
technology when people were still really
i think there's a little bit more
christmas spirit out there sometimes one
of the people that came to see me and i
did not realize who she was at the time
and one of the elves working on the set
said do you know who that was
and i said no that was hannah montana no
way
miley cyrus wow and i did not realize it
at the time
would she ask for do you remember no i
don't i'm sorry
well whatever it was it seemed like she
got it because she's been having yeah
she's had everything she's had
everything here's a question right here
from a young lady
hey theo hey mall santa hello my
question is what's the nastiest thing
that
has ever happened to you as a mall santa
baby barf you know dog poop what is it
what's the nastiest thing that's ever
happened
yeah do you ever is there ever accidents
with like children if they i'm sure huh
i've been fortunate over the years i've
not had too many
accidents happen while they're in my lap
but uh
from time to time a child will well
especially the really small ones not the
not the older the not the two or three
year old who's
who is uh scared they never vomit or
anything at least not
that's not been my experience sometimes
the little bitty ones that i hold yeah
the one with the head
a little bit okay ah
i've had a few children pee on me
oh wow uh especially if they get excited
now that's sometimes
we're out on your chest or where no
right here on your lap
and what'll happen is uh they'll get
excited
and then they just it just cuts loose
that's all there is
i guess the other if you want to call it
a nasty thing from time to time
especially
when you're towards the end of the
season and the lines are long
and people have had to wait in line a
long time and their children
will end up wetting themselves
what upsets me is when the parent
knows it but doesn't tell me they just
plop the child down because i have what
i call
pee pads that i could put on my lap to
keep my
suit from getting wet and as well as to
keep other children who sit there
afterwards from getting wet
safe yeah if they would just say
something wow
yeah i was wondering what you would do
so i guess you'd put a pad out or put
some flour out or something
you no what i do i have little red p
pads so it matches my
oh you guys think of everything santa i
have to
what's up all santa and theo gang gang
what's up
here's a question from all santa what's
the um
the worst gift that a child's ever asked
for where you thought to yourself
there's no way i'm getting you that
all right thanks for taking the time
today thank you merry christmas man
that's interesting yeah what
is it what's what's one of the gifts
you're like that's impossible or that's
not
even i always am careful about when
children are asking
for gifts i never promise that
i'll bring them ex gifts
i'll tell them i'll see what i can do
and i always
am looking to make sure that
what they're asking for is age
appropriate yeah
because sometimes they're wanting the
same thing that
an older sibling has but they're not
ready for that
gift yet do kids ever ask for are like
teenagers ever asked for anything that's
like perverse kind of like and you're
kind of like
you can't have that no teenagers
actually are
are mostly pretty good when they come to
see santa
the reason they're there is mom wants
that picture with santa
every year i've had some people
that have been coming to see me 40 and
50 years
wow they really coming every year
to get that picture so they can give it
to their mom one year i was at
uh when i was at cool springs there was
a ups
guy who delivered to the mall on the
very last day of the season
he and his son who also works for ups
would come and get that picture so they
could give it to his mom
and his son's grandmom oh that's cool
yeah
so there's a lot of people a lot of
there's a lot of tradition people come
through
to have a part of this same tradition
and stuff like that um have there ever
been a proposal in front of you
i probably had a half a dozen of them
over the years
yeah and now how does that usually go
down when it happens do they let you
know in advance
is it kind of uh does the is it a man
always proposing
uh all the ones i've had have been men
proposing to women
uh we've done it a bunch of different
ways
when i was in novi michigan
i was in kind of the center part of the
mall
and up above on the second floor was a
caged jeweler
and this young lady was sitting on my
lap
and her soon-to-be husband was up at
cage jeweler
and he came out to the to the uh
edge there and hot looked down
and hollered to us will you marry me
[Laughter]
and then he came on down the stairs in a
hurry and came to the set
and gave her the ring oh that's cool
another thing i've had was
they would come to the set ahead of time
and they would give me the ring and i
would have it in my pocket
and then they would be sitting on my lap
and
and i would always ask the woman what
she wanted for christmas and then i
would ask the guy what
he wanted for christmas and a lot of
times the guy would say this woman here
is the love of my life and i'd really
like to marry her
but things are really hard right now and
so i can't get her a ring
so then i'll reach in my best pocket and
i'll say well just a second
i think i may have something that'll
help you out and
of course give it to him and he opens it
up and
she's all a gas you know uh wow that's
the magic right there huh
and i'll tell you another thing that's
happened is uh birth announcements
okay i've had several people bring
with them uh to see me and they will
bring the sonogram
of the ultrasound that they had taken
and get you to autograph it or something
no i would hold it up they would be
sitting here and i would hold it up and
we'd be smiling and i would kind of
point at it yeah
yeah and people think you're the dad no
no no no
they don't i don't think they think that
but anyway would look
dude if santa was my dad you know
excited
if you would be like what does your dad
do like uh he works at the bank i'm like
oh my dad
santa my dad santa wow that's pretty
magical so
there's really an element too of your
job where it's just people where you
there's moments where you're really
involved in the magic of life
yes that's awesome man it's a lot of fun
i bet that's really awesome has there
been anybody that's come to see you
that's kind of been on their way out of
the world you know that's leaving life
and they wanted to come see santa one
more time
yes it's not so much
older people but it is
parents who bring their child who has a
terminal illness
and i always have a special bell
that i give to children like that and
about eight years ago i had given one to
this little
girl she had spina bifida and some other
problems going on in about uh
this was early in the season and
probably about a
week or 10 days later
the mom comes back and she's just
bawling in tears and then i realize who
she was
and she came back to tell me that her
child had died
and she buried her child with that bell
that i had given her
yeah it's interesting uh i think people
you you know they look to santa
i think as like a symbol of like hope
and
oh yeah love you know a symbol of magic
you know a symbol of what else uh could
be out there that we don't know
from time to time usually five or six
times a year
i will have a child come to me and tell
me santa
i don't want you to bring me anything
this year
i want my friend or my cousin or my mom
or my dad to get
a special christmas is that pretty
remarkable when you see that when a kid
asks yeah
and here's what i do first of all
if you think about children most
children are takers
they take stuff they want stuff given to
them oh yeah
they're very very few children that are
what i call
giver children they want to give to
other people
they don't want something for themselves
so when i when
that child when i see that child
and we're done with the visit i bring
the parents in
or the parent if there's only one that
came with them and i'll say do you know
what your child your little girl your
little boy asked me for
and they'll say no and i said
i'll then tell them the story of what
the child asked me for
and about half the time the parents will
know that they have
that that child's a giver child wow
about the other half of the time
the parents had no idea but they're
thrilled
that their child is that way
and i said i said and that's when i make
the
the gift of the bell to the child i have
the parent and the child there and i'm
explaining to them what's
what's transpired and i'll tell the
child that every time you ring that bell
i'll be thinking about you oh i love
that yeah
you know there's something special about
just being that uh it's almost to get
like you're like a middle man for um
yeah it's like you're like a middle man
for some of the joy that's out in the
world
right it must feel pretty interesting
sometimes it is it's it's a
it's a lot of responsibility but
it's uh gratefully accepted
responsibility
amen yeah yeah i bet to just to have to
be able to be like at work and have a
few moments like that
some people don't have moments like that
in their job their entire lives you know
so to be able to have that and then also
uh not only just like take it and
be like this is what i'm doing but take
it and just act the part
of being kind of just part of the
current right of whatever that good
energy is and i've had children as well
as adults
that asked me to pray with them and i
will pray with them
right there right there on the set
before they leave amen
are there a lot of good kids out there
you think oh yeah there are a lot of
great children out there
i like your attitude anything else we
got for santa sean
man santa we know you're so busy you
know
and we just thank you so much for
stopping by um
is there any other messages you have for
the kids out there i just want you all
to be happy with everything i bring you
and love what the elves have made you
take really good care of it because it
takes them a long time to make that
stuff
merry christmas let's uh
finish out this episode and i want to
wish everybody a merry christmas
and uh and i mean that from the bottom
of my heart and
um thank you for helping me be a part of
this and being a part of my life
and i mean that and um and i love you
and be good to yourself because you
deserve it
and i'm gonna try to do the same thing
and may we all
just have a be headed towards a
wonderful new year amen
all right let's go out um
on this lovely special by dusty
dex
um that ain't doing it for me so let's
go out on this special by timothy
in finite joy to the world
[Music]
okay none of this that's awesome let's
go out
um by
uh oh come all ye faithful
by grigori david
and there you go that's trappy right
[Music]
there
in the background
[Music]
i hope your new year is a remix i really
do
you guys be good man